today on the matt welsh show the
minneapolis school district instates a
policy of laying off white teachers
before black teachers this is supposed
to prevent systemic racism but how do
you prevent a thing from happening by
doing that very thing also the democrats
double down on their favorite strategy
emotional blackmail tragedy strikes cnn
and thus the entire nation sam harris
says that sometimes you have to subvert
democracy in order to save it does that
make sense in our daily cancellation the
new feminist she-hulk show premieres and
it's about as insufferable as you might
expect all of that and more today on the
matt wells show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when running a business you'll get hit
with all kinds of interesting scenarios
like an employee not showing up to work
on time mandatory sexual harassment or
workplace safety training wrongful
termination suits
minimum wage requirements labor
regulations all of that one complaint
can destroy your entire company the
problem is hr managers though are
expensive they can easily cost over 80
000 a year but with bambi you get access
to your own dedicated hr manager
starting at 99 a month all of bambi's hr
managers are based in the united states
and can support the nuances across all
50 states your manager is available by
phone email and real time chat to help
you effortlessly run employee onboarding
determinations encourage good
performance and make sure your business
stays compliant with ever-changing hr
regulations with bambi's hr autopilot
you can automate the most important hr
practices like setting policies training
and feedback in fact bambi clients are
four times less likely to have a
complaint filed against them so go to
bambi.com walsh right now for your free
hr audit you can run your business let
bambi run your hr spelled b-a-m-b-e dot
com slash walsh bambi.com walsh
early this morning the twitter account
for the lapd posted footage of what they
describe as a flash mob of looters
ransacking a 7-eleven in the city the
looters swarming like piranhas or
vultures take your animal of choice
there can be seen stealing candy and
bags of chips and
cigarettes and other necessary items
before they begin ripping the place
apart just sort of for the fun of it it
would seem now it may come as a shock to
um aoc but the one item left untouched
in the store is is the bread the bread
aisle is untouched i didn't see anyone
take any loaves of bread
none of the looters appear to be
starving in fact um
many of them seem to be very much on the
opposite end of the starving spectrum
let's just say
the other thing you don't see in the
footage of course is any sign of law
enforcement
now one might point out
that the lapd would be
better off showing up to the scene of
the crime
and carting the criminals away in
handcuffs rather than simply tweeting
about it after the fact
we have long had a problem in our
society with people filming crimes
rather than trying to actually stop them
and now even the police have adopted
this
strategy
now of course from the perspective of
the police
they know that the soros
d.a will will just release anyone they
arrest they also know that
if they have to get a little rough with
any with any of the precious innocent
children ransacking the convenience
store they'll end up in prison on hate
crime charges you know if they show up
there to make some arrests
and uh it turns out that some of the
people there don't want to be arrested
and so they
resist
and then the police god forbid have to
use physical force to detain the
suspects then it becomes well then it's
then it's a hate crime
so what are they going to do instead
they just post the video
but then the video doesn't matter
because the soros d.a
won't pursue or prosecute any of these
people
they could all be wearing name badges
with their addresses and phone numbers
on it and it wouldn't make a difference
they're not going to be held accountable
and worst of all they know it
that's the recipe for anarchy
and this is the anarchy that has
obviously gripped hold of our cities all
across the country
but
there are a few other ingredients
necessary to create a scene like the one
in that footage or in so many similar
incidents that we've witnessed
especially in recent years another
essential ingredient obviously is the
collapse of the nuclear family you know
if there were
100 people pillaging that 7-eleven i
don't know how many people it was let's
say it was 100. i'd be surprised if even
1 out of 100 lived in a house with both
a mom and a dad present
it's a general rule that kids with dads
at home
don't loot convenience stores now there
may be occasional exceptions to that
there's a reason why communities with
much higher rates of intact families
have much lower rates of mass looting
and other forms of criminality in fact
um
i don't know we'd have to take a look
but has there has there been has there
ever been mass looting in a community
with um
you know a fatherless rate
below like 50 if you can get oh if you
can even get over the 50 mark
with kids at home with mom and dad is
are there any examples of mass looting
in a community like that
another ingredient
though not unrelated to the others
is entitlement
you know the looters feel not only safe
and secure in their actions with the
knowledge that they'll not be held
accountable
but also importantly and this is the
part that maybe we don't talk about
enough
they feel morally entitled to behave as
they're behaving
indeed they've been explicitly told by
activists by the media
by powerful voices in congress like aoc
that they have every right to steal and
destroy as they see fit
the narrative of systemic racism has
allowed people like this to delude
themselves into believing that they're
oppressed by society and thus society
owes them something namely society owes
them whatever they feel like taking at
any given moment
they're victims and as victims they're
not responsible for their actions they
can do what they want
the leftist racial narrative allows them
to believe that systemic racism
is the biggest problem in their lives
and in their communities
even as they actively work to destroy
their lives and their own communities
the narrative self perpetuates in this
way
like you know we're often told about
food deserts in urban neighborhoods
that actually is one of the
justifications also given for looting
it's a food desert
it's the middle of a city but it's a
desert there's nowhere to get food
you know we're told that there's a lack
of grocery stores and convenience stores
and other
amenities
well and then we're told that this is
due to systemic racism
and yet
the stores that do exist in these
neighborhoods are targeted and
victimized
by the members of the neighborhood
the community violently chases
businesses away and then claims that the
void is caused by racism
this is the sort of destructive
incoherence brought about
by the systemic racism narrative
speaking of which
the systemic racism lie has given rise
to another even more egregious injustice
this week and this is a story that
hasn't um gotten nearly enough attention
so i'm gonna bring it to your attention
now if you haven't heard about it yet
the daily wire has the story
reading quote it says a minneapolis
teachers union is stipulating that white
teachers uh be laid off or reassigned
before educators of color quote unquote
allegedly to remedy the continuing
effects of past discrimination by the
district
minneapolis public schools have seen a
massive drop-off in student enrollment
leading to layoffs of teachers with
little seniority something that is
typical within the teaching profession
but the minneapolis federation of
teachers is opting for racial standards
before seniority to guarantee educators
of color protections according to alpha
news which reported this on sunday
starting with the spring 2023 budget
tie-out cycle if accessing a teacher who
is a member of a population
underrepresented among licensed teachers
in the site
the district shall access the the next
the next least senior teacher who is not
a member of an underrepresented
population according to the agreement
accessing refers to the reduction of
staff
teachers of color may be exempted from
district-wide layoffs outside of
seniority order the agreement says
adding that the reinstatement of
teachers from underrepresented
populations will be prioritized over
white teachers according to alpha news
the racial stipulation was added in part
in the name of social justice or to
remedy the continuing effects of past
discrimination by the district
past discrimination by the district
disproportionately impacted the hiring
of underrepresented teachers in the
district as compared to the relevant
labor market and the community and
resulted in a lack of diversity of
teachers the agreement reads now
as you might imagine
this policy
of firing the white teachers first which
is what it explicitly says well it
doesn't explicitly say that
what it explicitly says is we're going
to fire the or lay off or access
uh members of of of the over-represented
groups instead of underrepresented which
of course means white
now this is being criticized not the
least because it's blatantly illegal
i mean
at least technically in theory racial
discrimination in hiring and firing is
illegal
but just like the laws against looting
are not enforced neither are the laws
against racial discrimination
and the pushback and also the explicit
illegality of the plan have not swayed
the school district at all which
defended its racist practices in a
statement a few days later the new york
post reports quote the school district
released a statement to the washington
times on tuesday offering a
full-throated defense of the
groundbreaking deal with the minneapolis
federation of teachers led by president
greta callahan
the statement says to remedy the
continuing effects of past
discrimination minneapolis public
schools and minneapolis federation
teachers mutually agreed to contract
language that aims to support the
recruitment and retention of teachers
from underrepresented groups as compared
to the labor market and the community
served by the school district
so basically they're just restating what
they what the what the agreement says
in order to heal the wounds of racial
discrimination
they will engage in racial
discrimination
this is like i don't know trying to heal
the effects of rat poison
by giving the victim more rat poison
or you know what that's not actually the
right analogy that's wrong it's more
absurd than that
because this is healing the effects of
rat poison
by forcing some other guy to take rat
poison too
okay someone's been dosed with rat
poison and then the doctor shows up and
says i know what we're going to do about
this and then just grab some other guy
and shove some rat poison down his
throat see there you go now now two
people are poisoned
now that's what you do when you're not
interested in healing
instead you're interested in vengeance
no matter if the person you're getting
your revenge on
had anything to do with the alleged
crime that was supposedly committed
but this is the point
of the systemic racism narrative
it is to cede
resentment hatred
a lust for vengeance
and as we see among the looters an
unearned sense of entitlement as well
that's the whole idea and it's having
the
desired effect
now let's get to our five headlines
regardless of what the administration
defines as a recession americans are
nonetheless worried food and gas and
prices are higher than i've ever seen in
my lifetime which is why i'm so grateful
for my favorite meat delivery service
good ranchers while grocery store meat
prices continue to rise good ranchers
has your back their inflation-proof
model locks in your price the day you
subscribe for the life of your
subscription plus you can pause your
subscription for up to 90 days or cancel
anytime you want but you won't want to i
guarantee that not only that but good
ranchers is also currently running a
back to school give back program with
the goal of donating 100 000 high
quality meals this month to children in
need all you got to do is go to
goodranchers.com wall shoots code walls
to check out you'll get 30 off plus free
shipping you can subscribe to lock in
your price and recession proof your
meals for life and you can help these
guys reach their goal of donating 100
000 meals to children who may need it
going into the fall semester that's
goodranchers.com
walsh and remember as always to use
codewalsh at checkout
by the way a little bit of a
exciting personal news and an update we
did
um you know as you know we have another
set of twins on the way i think i've
mentioned that before
and so we were able to find out the
gender yesterday yes we we are we are
assigning a gender to our twins we're
not going to give them
if you could believe it
just like with with our other four kids
we're not giving them a choice in the
matter you know um
actually biology and nature isn't giving
them a choice in the matter so we
discovered that the twins are boys which
is uh which which actually came as a
shock you know my wife up until this
point i thought she had like magical
superpowers
because she can predict
the gender of a baby when it's still in
utero
and not only for our own babies but
other people and she's and she's always
right until now and so
she was like batting batting a thousand
on predicting these sorts of things and
then for for
our next set of twins she said oh
they're girls for sure i know that
turns out not so
the boys are taking over it's gonna the
girl's gonna be wildly outnumbered in my
family
and you know you always get the question
of uh well what what uh
you know which which is easier boys or
girls and
i don't i think it all balances out in
the end
but uh certainly for the first
you know 10 to 12 years of life
i think boys present
probably more of a challenge
and mainly the challenge is just like
keeping them alive keeping them from
destroying themselves and everything
else in the house
so that's the challenge that awaits us
which i will take on eagerly all right
um i want to start with something that
was put together by a group called the
american fire brand pack and i don't
know anything about this organization
but
they compiled this montage which they
posted on social media
and i think it's pretty powerful in that
it reveals the democrat strategy of
emotional blackmail
and this as we know is a strategy that
has gone into overdrive this week in
particular with all of the charges of
[ __ ] scholastic terrorism or whatever
it's called um incitement to violence
right where i'm being accused of that
libs of tick tocks being accused of it
conservatives in general being accused
of uh
we're going to kill people people are
going to die
because we're merely pointing out
what these children's hospitals and
quote unquote gender clinics are doing
to kids by pointing out the reality of
what's happening to kids
we we are going to end up killing people
and if you feel like you've heard that
before that line from from the left
well if you do this if you say this
people will die
if you feel like you've heard it before
it's because you have as this montage of
the democrats moral blackmail strategy
clearly shows watch this people are
dying people will die women are going to
die gail women will die
if you are also not going to allow trans
kids to play sports children will die
we've seen that trans kids suffer from
extremely high suicide rates to hear a
10 year old
say that they would rather die than
experience male puberty the most
comprehensive study to date on climate
change predicts more and more people are
going to die from air pollution if
changes are not made people are
suffering and dying people are dying
these policies kill people will die
people die how many more people have to
die to get some gun control your mistake
is killing the children in your state
this decision and this policy will kill
people we are also going to see a lot of
south dakota women die because of this
it's not an extreme statement to say
that women will die i thought i was
going to die people are dying
because of misinformation how many more
americans have to die
[Music]
people are dying and will die
who don't have to die
[Music]
this is a death cult let's get on with
the dying
people will die you know and actually
everything you heard there i mean the
basic uh underlying claim is is actually
true
and uh i am
sorry to have to be the one to always
break the news about this but it is true
that you know people will die everyone
will die that is the uh the consequence
of
being mortal human beings
now are they going to die because of
opinions that you've expressed
um are they going to die because of
because of realities that you have
pointed out
well obviously not
and the the irony of the of this
method from the democrats
going around all the time people will
die people will die we can't do this
because people are going to die
is it first of all from their
perspective since since when is that
even a bad thing they don't care if
people die
they hate people now as much as we just
heard from
beto there calling conservatives since
conservatism or or republicans you know
it's accusing us of being in a death
cult
oh really we're in a death cult
which
side is it again just remind me that has
overseen
the
systematic slaughter of 60 million human
beings in this country remind me again
which one that is remind me again which
side it is that that actually will say
that there's a that there are too many
people on earth and we need fewer of
them
which side is it that talks about human
beings like they're a cancer
a disease on the earth
i mean which side is actually openly
conspiring to
um
to limit the number of people who exist
remind me again so where's the death
cult
no in order for
the people will die thing to mean
anything you know in order for that to
motivate people you have to actually
cherish and value human life you have to
see human life as inherently
uh
valuable in some way and on the left
they they don't
and that's not a straw man or me making
a caricature of their position they
really don't
now they might not come out and say it
very often but if you press them on it
they will admit it
does human life have inherent value
their answer is obviously no
and
because if you believe that it had
inherent value to begin with you
couldn't support the slaughter of 60
million human beings in the womb
but also in order to see that human life
has inherent value then you know you
have to believe that there's some
uh that there's some
greater force some greater power out
there beyond just ourselves and our egos
but if we're all just clumps of tissue
walking around
and life has no inherent meaning then
it doesn't even matter if people die
doesn't matter if they live
so that's that's that's how the left
looks at it
and yet they still use
that people will die line to try to
manipulate us
well hopefully you know anyone listening
to this i don't need to tell you that
you shouldn't fall for that
especially when they're using it to try
to prevent you from from speaking the
truth
all right
i am i'm sorry we have to talk about
this because uh especially on a friday
you know i try to i try to keep it a
little bit lighter if i can
probably could have fooled you on that
one
but it is a time of great sadness in
america um it is a period of
mourning and lamentation
it began about a week ago when uh and i
don't even know if we ever talked about
this and i feel quite ashamed actually
that i think we may have
i may have inadvertently ignored it
so it was we got it back up to about a
week ago when the news was announced
that uh prominent masturbator jeffrey
toobin was leaving cnn after 20 years
now tubin
famous of course for pulling his tube
out
says the decision was mutual to leave
cnn um others are saying that it was
about as mutual as his decision to
fondle himself in the presence of his
colleagues on a zoom call which is to
say that in both cases the decision was
actually made by one party while the
other party recoiled
in
horror and was traumatized whatever the
case i don't know all we know now is
that jeffrey toobin is unemployed
and many fear will be left with
too much time on his hands
and who knows what else
on his hands
the good news is
he no longer has to you know put on his
pants and go to work not that he ever
saw the former as a necessary
prerequisite for the latter
and i don't say any of this by the way
um to make a joke about the esteemed
jeffrey toobin
or his unfortunate masturbatory
adventures um
i would never joke about that you know
frankly it's kind of low-hanging fruit
instead
i say all this as as a tribute um to the
man who gave so much of himself to his
job
some would say a bit too much of himself
actually
either way may he rest in peace with
both hands above the waist but tuban's
demise is not the only tragedy to befall
cnn
so that's what happened last week
um not the only tragedy to happen uh
to cnn and by extension to the entire
country or at least most of our airport
terminals it was announced this week
that the man
affectionately known as mr potato head i
think it's affectionate brian stelter is
leaving cnn this was the news yesterday
first we lost tubin
now we're losing stelter cnn reports
cnn's reliable sources with brian
stelter is coming to an end the company
announced thursday that it's ending the
media analysis show that has aired in
various iterations for 30 years its last
episode will be this sunday
as a result brian stelter will leave the
company a cnn spokesperson told cnn
business
so they're they're pretending that
they're not firing him it's just that
the show's going away
you know of course brian selter says
well i could do another show oh
no it's all right
that's okay we you know we'll let you go
do you know
well that's it's better if you just go
and work for someone else
uh they say we appreciate his
contributions to the network and wish
him well as he embarks on new endeavors
now
and then brian stelter said uh well who
cares what he says
you know
it was a it was
it was an interesting choice first of
all i was kind of interested by the fact
that they chose to announce the end of
brian stelter's show like this
because i'll tell you why it's
interesting because if they hadn't said
anything at all
nobody would have ever known
like they could have ended the show and
not told us and we would not have known
stelter is like the guy in office space
who uh who's the guy in office space who
was fired from his job but remained on
the staff for like five years and nobody
ever realized
milton
brian stelter is milton he's the milton
of cable news
something similar could have happened
here
like they could have just
ended the show and then 30 years from
now
thrown brian stell to a big retirement
party
and and congratulated him on three
decades of service to the company and
nobody would no one would be the wiser
anyway now stelter is unemployed also
looking for new opportunities and i'm
hopeful honestly and i know that i've
criticized him over the years um
and uh i've criticized him for you know
just being a
being a propagandist and a pawn who you
know his his show was
supposed to be a sort of like a media
criticism show
that's the way it was positioned as sort
of the ombudsman type role where he's
he's criticizing
the media and keeping a watch on the
media but all he ever actually did was
defend the media against legitimate
criticisms
and so i've criticized him for that but
the truth is that i i am hopeful that he
finds a new job that um
i'm hopefully defines a job that gives
him an even bigger audience
maybe for example he could deliver the
morning announcements at his local
middle school
that'd be kind of a step up i don't know
and the truth obviously is for brian
stelter that he had
the real problem is that
once
trump went away he had nothing left to
talk about
and there are many cases like this this
is this is the the crisis that the media
has faced
for a few years now
that their entire
brand and personality centered around
trump and then trump left and um they've
had years to figure something else out
and they just haven't been able to do it
which is why i mean never believe
anything anything otherwise they they
desperately desperately want trump
to run again and they want him back in
the white house
anyway so that's the sad news brian
stelter and jeffrey toobin all right i
want to play this clip this is something
i was making the rounds yesterday uh sam
harris was
on
um
the trigonometry podcast which by the
way i appeared on a podcast as well a
few
uh days ago and you can go to their
youtube channel and watch that episode
and after you do that um or or i guess
you could do that after you watch this
clip this is uh sam harris also on the
same podcast
who
you know was a to put it mildly
is is a trump critic doesn't like trump
and he was asked about
some of the dirty tricks that were
pulled
especially when it comes to the hunter
biden laptop story
that ended up you know resulting in
biden getting elected as the media and
big tech conspire to suppress these
stories
uh does he have any ethical qualms about
that and and
sam harris says no let's listen to the
clip
i mean hunter button at that point
hunter bind literally could have had had
the corpses of children in his basement
i would not have cared right it's like
it's there's nothing first of all it's
hunter biden right it's not it's like
it's not joe biden but
even if joe like even whatever scope of
joe biden's corruption is like if you if
we could just go down that rabbit hole
endlessly and and
understand that he's getting kickbacks
from hunter biden's deals in ukraine or
whatever else right or china
it is
infinitesimal
compared to the corruption we know trump
is involved in it's like it's like it's
like a firefly to the sun right i mean
like there's just it doesn't even it
doesn't even stack up against trump
university
right trump university as a story
is worse than anything that could be in
in hunter biden's laptop in my view
right now that's not that doesn't answer
the people who say it's still completely
unfair
to not have looked at the laptop in a
timely way and to have shut down the you
know the new york post's twitter account
like that that's a just a conspiracy
that's a left-wing conspiracy to deny
the presidency too
one second
um
and usually sam harris is a pretty clear
i don't know i don't agree with with
much of what he says but he's usually
seems to me to be a pretty clear thinker
and not on this
you know because
there there's a lot of contradiction
happening here starting with the fact
that that he says um well trump is worse
because his crimes are worse allegedly
right he claims
he's done a lot worse things
and so that's why we have to do whatever
we can to keep him out of office
but then he also says i wouldn't care
what what joe biden did
so
trump is worse because he's done worse
things
but
even if biden did worse things which by
the way you know killing children and
having them in the basement i understand
this was meant to be hyperbole but he's
he's making the point whether with
hyperbole or not
that literally no matter what he did it
it it uh he still would have preferred
biden over trump
so i mean do you think that trump is
actually literally the worst person like
no one could have ever ever be worse
than donald trump i guess is what you
believe
so on one hand he's basing his
assessment
on
you know what what he believes trump has
done versus what biden has done what
they're both guilty of doing but then on
the other hand he says it doesn't really
matter what they do so that doesn't make
a lot of sense to me
also the other thing that he's missing
completely here
is that how do we know
about corruption
from elected officials and powerful
people
especially presidents
i mean how do we know if they're corrupt
or not do they announce it
are we relying on them to come out and
and just tell us yeah
here's here are my examples of
corruption everybody here it is
no no we need people to tell us
and that's
traditionally what you need the news
media for
because the average person is not in a
position to investigate the corruption
of a powerful elected official so we
need someone to do it and tell us
so are you not curious about that i mean
are you not wondering that okay
like whatever trump has done
we know all of it because there is the
media is obsessed with finding
everything he's got he's got the entire
federal government coming after him
so there are no secrets here
all of trump's sins have been laid to
bear
because there are a lot of very powerful
forces that are extremely interested in
finding out what those things are and
telling us
but sam are you not
are you not seeing the issue here
that for democrat presidents
there aren't any powerful forces even
interested in finding out what the
corruption might be
so when you say that trump is more
corrupt than biden what is that even
based on
now by the way it's it's also not true
like even even looking at the corruption
we know about from biden it is worse
than trump
hands down far and away
but my point is that
like the
corruption we know about that's uh
that's a that's an important qualifier
there because the things we know about
are only the things that slip through
the cracks
all right let's play the rest of the
clip
trump
absolutely it was absolutely right but i
think it was warranted right and i'm and
again it's a coin toss as to whether or
not sam i'm sorry that particular piece
i'm really sorry i i was the one that
said we should move on but you've just
said something i really struggle with
that which is
the kid the kids in the basement you no
no
the kids in the basement i'm interested
in democracy you're saying you are
content
with the left-wing conspiracy to prevent
somebody being democratically re-elected
as president well no i i'm conte well so
it's but the thing is it's just not
left-wing right so liz cheney is not
left-wing right liz cheney is doing
everything in her policy to prevent
somebody being democratic it's not like
no but there's nothing conspiracy it's
not it was a conspiracy out in the open
it does but it doesn't matter if it
doesn't matter what parts conspiracy
what parts out in the open i mean i
think it's like if people get together
and talk and talk about what should we
do about this phenomenon you know if
it's like if there was an asteroid
hurtling toward earth
and and we got in a room together with
all of our friends and had a
conversation about what we could do to
deflect its course right
is that a conspiracy
uh so trump was a an asteroid
set to destroy life on earth
you know it it more incoherence here
because trump is
allegedly a threat to democracy and
that's what makes him so
dangerous and that's why we have to do
everything we can to stop him
but yet you're subverting the democratic
process to stop him
[Music]
because you think he's a threat to the
democratic process so
you're destroying the democratic process
to save the democratic process i think
we've heard that kind of thing but it
reminds me of who's it george bush
said we have to abandon the free markets
to save the free markets i believe was
his famous quote infamous quote
but this is also ends justify the means
which is what you get on the left
it's like
you could do whatever you want
um
as long as you get the result you want
all that matters is the result
and anything done in service to that
result is automatically okay because of
the result
so that's what he's that is what he is
actually struggling to defend here is
the ends justify the means
mentality and the reason he's struggling
to defend it is because it is a morally
incoherent
um
philosophy
all right speaking of uh moral
incoherence so here's a study from
axios and it is
i haven't even looked at these results
yet but i just saw this pop up and i'm
reading it now
so this is uh they are examining the
differences between public and private
opinions
and they say self-silencing people
saying what they think others want to
hear rather than what they truly feel
is skewing our understanding of how
americans really feel about abortion
covenanting precautions what children
are taught in school and other hot
button issues according to a new study
the best predictor of private behavior
is private opinion people's actual views
are far more likely than their stated
views to drive consumer and social
behavior and voting
so
this is
analyzing public versus private opinion
in in individuals
which already i'm not sure how you
measure that exactly
because whatever they're you have to you
have to ask them right and so whatever
they're telling you is i guess their
public opinion because they're saying it
out loud
the private opinion is what they believe
in their heads
but there's no way to measure that
really because the moment they say it
out loud that it's no longer the private
opinion
so i'm seeing some problems here already
but let's go ahead
uh it says by the numbers on abortion
the study found that men are much less
likely to privately agree with the idea
that the choice to have an abortion
should be left solely to a woman and her
doctor
then would say so publicly 45 to 60
wait okay the study men are less likely
to agree with the idea
that the choice to have an abortion
should be left to a woman and her doctor
republicans meanwhile were less likely
to privately say roe v wade should be
overturned than publicly
on education americans overall are
privately more supportive of parents
having more influence over curriculum
than proclaim this publicly 60 to 52
americans are less concerned about
teachers talking about gender identity
or how much public schools focus on
racism than they say publicly
only about half of americans actually
think it's inappropriate for schools to
discuss gender identity in kindergarten
through third grade compared to the 63
who say so publicly okay right
um all right sorry i wasted your time
with this
absolute nonsense study
right so
people are
more conservative publicly is what
you're trying to tell us on issues of
gender identity than they are privately
obviously the exact opposite is the case
so what they want us to believe is that
there are a whole bunch of americans
running around saying that they don't
want to teach kindergarteners about
gender identity they say that publicly
but privately they really want it to
happen
right
um
that's not even close to true
it actually makes no sense whatsoever
because there's no
the the self-regulation happens the
other way people present themselves as
more liberal in public than they
actually are in private that's how the
self-regulation works
and how do i know that well very simply
because that's where all of the social
incentive is there's no social incentive
to pretend to be more conservative than
you actually are
zero
and also
the
the punishment
goes against the conservative view
because all of our most powerful
institutions
demand that we have liberal viewpoints
on these subjects especially on subjects
like gender
media academia the government everywhere
hollywood
big tech
so all of the social pressure
falls on on trying to to make people uh
you know
be more liberal on these subjects
and yet we're supposed to believe based
on this study that uh that somehow
people people actually intentionally
put themselves in line
for social ostracization
and punishment
by pretending to be more concerned by
adopting more unpopular views at least
unpopular in the minds of our elites
it makes no sense whatsoever
but thanks for doing this study anyway
all right one other thing i want to
mention here
interesting story
it says a pastor in missouri rain down a
fiery sermon upon his flock one sunday
this month
scolding parishioners for failing to
follow god
the reverend carlton thunderbirk
condemned his congregation not because
they'd sinned too much or loved god too
little or done too few good deeds out in
the world instead thunderbird rebuked
the cheap sons and daughters of the
church of the of the well in kansas city
for not honoring him by buying him a
luxury watch
now i'll play this clip for you i
watched this clip and i and i you know i
immediately thought okay
you always have to keep in mind context
and when you see a clip and it's 30
seconds or 50 seconds what happened
before and after that
is there some kind of context here that
would make this sound
not as horrible as it sounds well
apparently not because this this pastor
has since apologized for this
clip ex that you're about to watch right
now um here it is let's listen
see that's how i know you still poor
broke busted and disgusted because of
how you've been honoring me
i'm not worthy of mcdonald's money
i'm not worth your red lobster money
i ain't worth your saint john nick
y'all can't afford it know-how
i ain't worth y'all louis vuitton
come on i ain't worth your
product i'm not worth your gucci
[Music]
mother oh i'm saying this and i promise
your dignity is not with respect and
won't i'm saying it because i want you
to understand just what god is saying
even found out that movado you can buy a
bottle watch in sam's yes you can
and y'all know i asked for one last year
here it is the whole way in august i
still ain't got it y'all ain't saying
nothing let me kick down the door and
talk to my cheap sons and daughters
now uh
this is obviously wildly inappropriate
and actually insane
this is uh this is that's like
prosperity gospel on on steroids really
i mean this
prosperity gospel unfortunately
is uh very very popular
um
and
and even if the if the advocates of it
rarely will will you know identify
themselves as such but prosperity gospel
is the idea that uh you deserve to be
blessed
with with uh with
with actual riches like physical riches
um if you're a holy person that god will
will will reward you
with physical
wealth and riches in this world
and that you deserve it
now of course that's pretty much
diametrically
to what christ actually says in the
gospels
so which is why it's not the actual
gospel it's the prosperity gospel
that's kind of what we're hearing here
much more direct than what you're used
to hearing
that said you also see what a what a
what a
advantage it is to have a powerful
preacher voice and cadence
because you could get up there
complaining that you're that you weren't
given a watch and people in the
congregation are saying hey man that's
right
the power of being a good public speaker
you can see what
you can see the advantages there
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
[Music]
some states now have laws that say as
early as the 2030 model year new
vehicles will have to be electric in
order to be registered cars with
internal combustion engines will only be
able to get license plates if they were
built before the end of the 2020s which
means that people are going to be going
to keep repairing and driving their old
cars for generations it also means you'd
better go to rockauto.com right now and
order all the parts to properly maintain
and repair your car
your great grandkids might be driving
that car someday so you gotta take care
of it rockauto.com has been in the auto
parts business for 20 years family owned
their goal is to make auto parts
available and affordable to keep you
safe on the road for as long as possible
rockauto.com's online parts catalog is
incredibly easy to use you can search
all the parts available for your
specific car suv or truck with photos
specs and installation tips as well not
only will they have the part you need
but they'll usually give you that
several trusted brands to choose from
also rockauto.com kits are popular
because they bundle together all the
parts you need for successful repair
you've got everything you need right in
one place all you gotta do is go to
rockauto.com get brake shocks carpets
wipers headlights mirrors everything you
need at rockauto.com be sure to write
walsh in their how did you hear about us
box so they know that i sent you
before we get to the comments here i
wanted to um
if i could get serious yet again and i'm
sorry i have to keep on doing this but
um
i have been talking about on this show
for the past couple of weeks
you know while other shows have focused
on less important issues
i have been talking quite a bit about
um
the issue related to my giant stuffed
walrus which as you know
was apparently purchased for me as a
gift
by this company
and yet never given to me
uh no explanation
has ever been offered
for why my giant stuff walrus was was
why i
was uh
deprived of it and still am deprived of
it
and you know as we've been talking about
this and i and i and and i can tell you
that here at work i've been i've been
investigating
i can't get anyone else to take the
investigation seriously it's like
everyone else here they're just
whistling past the graveyard every day
all wrapped up
in whatever they're doing
and no one is taking seriously the fact
that there's a giant stuffed walrus
somewhere out there that i have not been
given even though it's mine
so in my investigation i stumbled across
this and i i have to tell you
i was
stunned when i saw this
this is a video this is true
this is a video from ben shapiro's
instagram account
which was posted back in june
and it's been sitting there no one ever
told me about it
i just want you to see this video watch
[Music]
i think walsh hit this a little bit too
far
[Music]
get your hands off my wallers ben first
of all that's not yours that's mine
so you see okay number one you can see
the giant i told you it's giant that's
the stuffed walrus
so
now i'm just trying to figure out what's
going on here
that i was not given the stuffed walrus
but you but we you were using it for for
an instagram video for ben
does ben have it
okay i i don't know we're going down the
rabbit hole here and uh and i and i'm
starting to get
frankly disturbed by what i'm finding
but i will not relent
all right alexandra de
berdeja says
uh
matt walsh's mouth welcome to the
members only segment my personal
favorite part of the show matt walsh's
brain i can't believe dw has me doing
this stupid stuff i want to go home
that's not true
i'm i'm very excited about doing the
members only segment which we know which
we have added to the end of the show
uh because i everyone knows that you
know i love nothing more than talking to
begin with and um
and i've i i'm always saying how at the
end of the show after talking for an
hour uh i want nothing more than to
continue talking some more like i'm
always saying that and and so you know
being given the opportunity is very
exciting for me
that's that's sincere
hugh jarsal says
is it me or did matt basically confirm
it was dominoes he witnessed this poor
behavior at i realized they may be
banned for for this um i can confirm nor
deny
what pizza place i worked for um i i
just
you know i i will say that
at least when i was working in in that
industry there were all kinds of things
you know that i witnessed behind the
scenes that
most of it having to do with with food
safety and sanitation
but uh it's it's just it's made me less
enthusiastic about eating pizza from
those kinds of places i will say
uh samuel hayes says matt's not wrong
about the pizza thing my pal worked for
a cece's that swept ingredients up
rinsed them and made a pizza with the
floor toppings meanwhile i worked for a
local pizza place where the cooks
sniffed cocaine off of the same counters
that they chopped ingredients on
see a little bit of cocaine on the pizza
i don't know if people will see that as
a disincentive or not
um
bean says it's not illegal to yell fire
in a crowded theater why are we still at
this lmao
yeah the fire crowded theater thing has
been used that was
used against me this week it's
incitement by talking about boston
children's hospital and we know the fire
and crowded theater thing is a it's a
it's a stupid cliche
uh but but even more so
you know one of the reasons why it's
especially absurd in this case
is that
we could we could talk about the
scenarios and the the legality of crying
fire in a crowded theater when there's
no fire
but certainly if there actually is a
fire then
we could all agree that not onl not only
is it okay to yell fire but um if you
saw a fire in a theater and didn't tell
anybody and maybe just snuck out the
door yourself and left everyone to die
in the inferno then uh then at the very
least that's immoral if not illegal
so that's what makes the charge so
especially absurd
because when we talk about the fact that
boston children's hospital or any other
children's hospitals or clinics are
castrating and sterilizing kids
and we're yelling fire in that sense
well there actually is a fire
it is really happening
and so what the left is saying is um no
even if the theater is on fire and
everyone's going to die don't tell
anyone
keep your mouth shut
let that let them enjoy the you know the
last few minutes of the film before they
all burned to death that's what the left
is saying
um
and
finally mike says matt on the tipping
conversation if we paid people a living
wage then it wouldn't be necessary
to tip
well first of all it depends i mean you
know we use this term living wage like
it's supposed to have some kind of
objective meaning
what what do you what do you mean by
living wage if you mean by living wage
a wage that someone could live off of on
their own and support themselves
indefinitely
well
not every job was meant
for that purpose right like not every
job is is meant to be a career for an
adult
to have and and keep for years on end
and so for
example you know working
a mcdonald's drive-thru
is is not meant to be a career where
you're supporting yourself and a family
off of it
it's it's these are really jobs meant
for like kids
and high school students and you know
people working part-time
for some extra money
um and as far as the tipping part it
just we did talk about this in the
members segment yesterday and uh and i
think i've talked about before on this
show but all i'm i'm not anti-tipping
i'm i've actually always been a believer
in tipping and i think i'm pretty good
taper but we just need to we're always
being told we need to have national
conversations about this and that
subject this is a subject where we
actually need a national conversation
and we need to talk about what what
jobs actually deserve and warrant a tip
and which don't because right now it is
just totally out of control
uh and it's it's we can mainly blame it
on the stupid little ipad things that
people use now
if instead of cash registers because
they just flip it around and say would
you like to leave a tip
and it's like no i don't not neces no
you hand me a cup of coffee why do i
want to leave a tip for that you were
running a cash register i ran a cash
register when i was a kid i never asked
for a tip for it
this is an important conversation we
should have
well the story of my plight
has been heard far and wide as i have
whined about it incessantly as you're
all aware the giant walrus that was
created and planned as a gift for me is
still hidden somewhere within
these walls how can you hide a giant
walrus well i don't know the outcry of
support in addition to the condemnation
of those guilty of withholding the
gentle semi-aquatic beast is uh is
welcome and it's also uplifting and yet
the hope i've drawn from my sweet babies
pales in comparison to the devastation
of this agonizing forceful separation
it is literal violence some might even
say stochastic terrorism against me
that's why this month's patch
is the hashtag give matt his walrus
patch
they've made a patch the the very people
responsible for the abomination plaguing
me while i was ravaged by laryngitis are
monetizing my suffering
but in this case i'm okay with it so go
to dailywire.com shop to get the latest
installment of the matt welsh patch
program
i can't believe they're making me do
this i feel like a hostage reading my
own captors demands
can they do this why are they doing this
they actually took the time to write
this out these questions i'm asking i'm
writing right now
my own my own existential crisis i'm
reading from a teleprompter at this
moment i'm still reading copy right now
this is not
stopping this is cruel almost a scroll
as not being given my walrus so go buy
the patch also last week was a week like
no other i triumphed over my illness and
was able to release the 1 000th episode
of the matt wall show 1 000 episodes is
a massive milestone in my career but
that's not that's only just the
beginning if uh if you want to see one
of the most important things i've ever
done in my lifetime you have to check
out my documentary what is a woman it
has more than 5 000 audience ratings on
rotten tomatoes even has five brave
critics who were willing to review it
and they all gave it a thumbs up
just uh in the month after we released
what is a woman the daily wire gained
more members than at any other time in
our history
it just goes to show that uh if you make
something worth watching unlike most
hollywood films people will watch it in
droves so if you haven't seen it go to
whatiswoman.com and watch it right now
that's what is a woman.com today now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so earlier in the month it was announced
that warner brothers would be shelving
their new batgirl film after having
already spent 90 million dollars to
produce it the move was devastating for
batgirl's fan but it made sense from a
financial perspective the studio
realized that the film would be a
massive embarrassing flop and decided
that they'd rather just take the tax
write-off than cut their losses now of
course if they'd asked me
i could have told them before they even
made the movie that a movie called
batgirl would be terrible
i mean replacing batman with a 97 pound
female it's like remaking jaws
except with a with a dolphin
and on second thought that analogy
probably makes batgirl seem more
interesting than it really is
although we'll never know for sure as
the studio executives have taken the
batgirl film
and thrown it into a volcano ensuring
that nobody ever sees it and it never
falls into the wrong hands
but the untimely demise of batgirl has
created a void now the public is
clamoring for a new feminist superhero
to step in and carry the mantle
well really nobody is clamoring for a
feminist superhero literally nobody on
earth that's the whole reason why
batgirl ended up in the volcano to begin
with be that as it may hollywood is
ready to ready to deliver what nobody
actually asked for or wanted and this
week marvel's new series she-hulk
debuted on disney plus
even before the show premiered the cast
had already started using the batgirl
tragedy as a means of morally
blackmailing both the studio and the
public into supporting their project the
headline on yahoo news reads after
batgirl cancellation she-hulk cast and
creators stressed the importance of
studios supporting female-led superhero
projects
translation
you all better pretend to actually like
this book we produced or you're all
sexist
the message is made clear in the article
says marvel boss kevin fage was among
the first to reach out to batgirl
directors adil l arby and baleel falah
who also worked on ms marvel to express
his support after the cancellation news
likewise the team behind she-hulk shared
their sympathy
it is so hard to imagine the
disappointment that those filmmakers
must be feeling because these projects
take years says she-hulk director and
executive producer kat koro
i've been working on this for years and
the idea of it never seeing the light of
day is well it must be crushing shalk
has long been regarded as one of the
most powerful feminist icon found in the
pages of comic books making the arrival
of attorney at law all the more
impactful at this particular moment in
time
coiro says it's exciting because just
her very existence is a feminist she's
large she's in charge she controls her
own narrative the mcu has for a very
long time been very male heavy there
hasn't been a lot of female
representation
so it's nice to finally start making
some progress in that area
now i do agree that large
is quite often an app description of
feminist i'm not sure about the rest of
it though in any case the blackmail
worked and she-hulk despite being just
as humiliatingly terrible as batgirl
would have been was allowed to debut and
be seen by literally dozens of people
one particular clip from the show's
premiere has been making the rounds
online though helped by the imdb db
twitter account which tweeted the video
with the caption ahem say it louder for
the people in the back
the clip shows she-hulk
lecturing regular hulk about how
difficult her life is because of course
the whole reason audiences flock to
superhero shows is to hear their
favorite superheroes complain and feel
sorry for themselves here's the clip
here's the thing bruce i'm great at
controlling my anger i do it all the
time
when i'm catcalled in the street
when incompetent men explain my own area
of expertise to me i do it
pretty much every day because if i don't
i will get called
emotional or difficult or
might just literally get murdered so i'm
an expert at controlling my anger
because i do it infinitely more than you
as we can see self-pity is she-hulk's
superpower her high-pitched whining is
enough to make any super villain
flee out of just sheer annoyance
of course the experiences she describes
in that monologue which was apparently
curated from a twitter thread written by
a jezebel blogger are all at worst
mild annoyances
i mean if those experiences are the
worst hardships in your life then you
have led an exceedingly privileged
existence
and trying to explain
why her life is so much harder than
bruce's she-hulk can only mention the
trauma of receiving unwanted compliments
and of having her credentials questioned
and she then says that she can't
complain about these experiences because
if she does she'll be insulted or
murdered
the interesting thing about this claim
is that it's it's not only delusional
and insane but also self-negating she
clearly has no problem complaining and
is quite eager to do so and far from
being killed for it she's instead hailed
as a hero
this is a common theme with the
feminists that they claim that they're
not able to talk about their troubles
when in fact that's the only thing they
ever talk about
and any time one of them does talk about
it the others say yeah finally someone
said it what i mean finally someone said
it this is all we've heard this a
billion times
but simply exaggerating your own
sufferings is one thing you know we can
all tend to fall into that trap
sometimes the real problem with
she-hulk's approach here and with the
approach of feminists in general is the
assumption that no man could ever suffer
or does ever suffer like women suffer
she-hulk declares her struggles to be
infinitely more numerous and severe than
bruce's or any other man's
now we could maybe ignore the claim if
it was just coming from a character
called she-hulk but the problem is that
this is the attitude that our society
seeks to foster in girls that's why they
put it in the monologue to begin with
in truth there is nothing to be gained
by comparing two groups against each
other and trying to determine who has a
harder time of it but if that is the
game we're playing
most of the statistical evidence would
seem to suggest that in modern america
women generally have the better deal
that's why girls are more likely to
graduate high school less likely to be
suspended or expelled women are less
likely to commit suicide to become drug
addicts to become hopeless to homeless
to
less likely to suffer from workplace
injuries women are less likely to be the
victims of violent crime they're less
likely to be blown to pieces on the
battlefield
but sure i guess the homeless
drug-addicted suicidal war injured
veteran on the street probably doesn't
get cat called very often so he's got
nothing on she-hulk
now nobody is suggesting that women have
no challenges or obstacles to overcome
but the idea that they have more
obstacles than men or more serious ones
is just not borne out by the facts i'm
sorry
and besides as already noted the
comparisons are absurd and pointless the
only thing worse than being self-pitying
is to be competitive in your self-pity
it's bad enough to walk around dwelling
on your misfortunes it's even worse to
insist that you win the prize for the
most misfortunate person in the world
and it's especially ridiculous to make
this claim when you are a young
attractive woman in the modern western
world
because our modern society is
essentially tailor-made to facilitate
the happiness and success of that
category of people
this has probably been a more serious
analysis of a she-hulk monologue than
was necessary but someone has to
mansplain these things to her and i was
more than happy to step up to the plate
and someone must especially say to
she-hulk
that you ma'am
are canceled
and that'll do it for us
for this portion of the show as we move
on to the post show or move on to the
next segment rather
and if you're not following us over
there then godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by jeff tomlin our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.